here
are some simple quick beauty tips from
someone who
really knows what they're talking about
oh my god
guys there is a goop
body butter coming out on september 27th
and it is the greatest body butter of
all time
you just scoop it in thick nourishing
and then you rub it
so i have a beauty secret for you all
that you gotta listen to
if you were wondering if you should wear
sunscreen
indoors the answer is yes
see people forget that you have windows
or the sun is coming
in so your skin is still being damaged
so
if you put a little sunscreen on while
you're in your house it will protect
your skin
while you're inside and then protect it
when you go outside
trust me your skin will look flawless
this is really a life or death like for
real life hack
like make sure you're getting a good
night's sleep as much as you know you
say insomnia all these different things
like figure it out
one of the things that's helped me to
get even deeper sleep when i go to sleep
at night
is to take a spoonful of raw honey
before i go to bed
that's supposed to be really good for
you doesn't mess with your digestive
tract because you don't really want to
eat too much just before you go to bed
um but it does act as brain food for you
while your body's doing all its repairs
so that one's a fun life hack so get
some good sleep and
have a little bit of raw honey
as your medicine as your sugars will
have the medicine go down
sleep well everybody i'm gonna be
shallow and do a beauty tip because
i have i don't wanna say problematic
skin because i don't want my skin to
feel bad
but it is very it's kind of like all
over the place one day it's feeling good
the other day it's feeling like a little
sassy
so i do once a week i do a dry clay mask
by mario badescu
and it is a game changer is really help
with my acne so i say once a week
leave it on your face for 20-25 minutes
wash it off
your face will smell like sulfur for
like a few hours but it's so
worth it to have clearer skin that was a
beautiful tip
i can't wait to incorporate that tip
into my routine
beautiful and brilliant